Tung Anh thành phố Vinh bắt sự nằm mấy mốt bảo tu vụ măng kêu hàng nống,
lạc lạc lạc, lãnh trọng, nèt bố, dịch đủy trên đường phố, theo không ăn thành phố Vinh,
gần gái trên đẹp bàn sức hiện lý ô nhau đối trực trong độ tuổi thành kêu niên,
có những hình vì cây dối tiếp ấn phạc tháp.
Trong đó, có một số nhau hối tiếp các đẹp bàn lần cận y lập thì giả cửa lỏ,
việc nước bên và tĩnh hả tĩnh đến đẹp bàn thành phố Vinh để hát lậu.
Phúc nhóm thành kêu niên, dự kỳ xe phố tố, măng kêu hộ khi giáo, giếm, lạc lạc lãnh vọc, nèt bố, dịch đủy,
trực hiện hành vi đi giả pháp lợc, phố ý gây thương tích và cây dối chất tự công tộc,
chùiếu là vào định biệt.
Mấy đây, công ăn thành phố Vinh đã phá thành công trên an,
hát sức nằm mấy mốt đối trực, tương mề bố định đẹp về tả tuổi,
tổ dữ nhiều rau, giếp tự trế, của một số tăng vật lịch con khát,
bước đầu đã làm gió, qua mạnh sống hộ,
hát nhóm đối trực của các địa bàn lất cậu dự hệ đi lộ,
tý sát khởi lọc, gửi đương miên, và tình hát tính,
quen biết và hẹn nhau tại thành phố Vinh để thể hiện bàn thân.
Ghiện đã khởi tố phố ăn, khởi tố bị cân,
hát sục lịch pháp nằm chạm tạm dạm đối với bà viên mốt đối trực,
để tổ dữ giấu chạm thử công cộng và cuối gây thương tích,
sự lý đi bạm hành trị đối với hai môi đối trực có lịch quan.